let's bring in fox news senior political
analyst brit hume to talk about the
varying responses to the pandemic
different states you heard that piece
break good evening
what about the the different ways
governors are handling it we're seeing
for example florida governor desantis
and then california governor
gavin newsom two very different uh ways
of handling kovid
newsom is up for a recall election
currently
yeah and desantis remains highly popular
in florida after
imposing much lighter regulations than
were imposed in california and of course
the
the the data show that they're that
california and florida in terms of
the of covid deaths hospitalizations
cases and so on
are roughly comparable which suggests
that these
stringent lockdowns that have were
imposed in california don't really work
at least they don't work any better than
the later regulations imposed elsewhere
and of course in here in florida where i
am happen to be right now
you know things have been mostly open
schools have remained open restaurants
are open so forth people take
precautions
you see masks everywhere but it but the
lighter
regulatory approach seems to have worked
very well and without as i say the
tremendous collateral effects in terms
of health in other ways
uh children's education children's
health
suicides and all the rest of it so i
think that
we're going for a long debate when all
this is over about which approach worked
best but the evidence seems to be
mounting
that a lighter regulatory approach in a
situation like this can work just as
well as a heavy one
yeah and just to put up those stats that
you just referenced there uh
covert on the coast here california and
florida cases in california
three million five hundred thousand a
little bit more than that as of march 15
deaths fifty five thousand uh florida
cases there you see them one point nine
uh million deaths thirty two thousand uh
do you buy this criticism from some
that the administration is trying to use
covid
to move its priorities that may be not
even tied to covet
if you look at that that bill and maybe
what they're
they're trying to do forward going
forward i do buy that brett i don't
think there's any doubt about it and if
you look at what's in the bill
only a fraction of it is directly
related or even in some cases indirectly
related to coveted relief a lot of it is
just the democratic party's wish list to
bail out states that are in trouble for
budgetary problems and the rest of it
and i think that
you know that i thought by the way a lot
of people thought actually when biden
would became president that the crisis
would
would just mysteriously disappear
but but i think that the democrats have
found keeping it going useful
for their legislative agenda and for
other purposes
and for the fact that you know some
democrats just like to regulate more
than republicans do and
this has been the greatest cause for
regulation that we've seen in my
lifetime
so i think those things are both fed
into it but you know i
i think you know we're seeing now that
lighter regulation works every bit as
well and in some respects much better
than the heavy regulations we've been
under obviously health officials like
fauci and others dr fouch and others are
warning about
not going too fast and have been over on
the weekend
shows as well one quick thing and that's
about the filibuster the way that
they could get other legislation through
the democrats would be to change the
filibuster filibuster the 60-vote
threshold in the senate
take a listen to senator durbin earlier
today
about this on the floor today's
filibuster has turned the world's
most deliberative body into one of the
world's most ineffectual bodies
today's filibuster is often used to
prevent the senate from even starting to
debate important ideas
it's not the guarantor of democracy
it has become the death grip of
democracy
now it's really interesting brett i mean
a lot of these senators including durbin
have long talked about how the senate is
a tradition and this should be protected
there's a definite tone
change here about moving forward well
the filibuster basically requires on
most forms of legislation 60 votes
to get it to the floor or otherwise pass
it
and that's been true for as long as you
know we can remember at least in recent
history
the problem that durbin and company are
having is not the fact that the
filibuster exists it
it has existed for a long time and has
been used for a long time by both
parties
the problem is it's a 50 50 senate and
you're not going to be able to pass a
massive legislative agenda with such a
tiny little mandate if indeed it's a
mandate at all
so i think that's the proper way to look
at this and the complaining of the
filibuster is the death grip of
democracy is absurd
brett as always thank you thank you